[Музика]
привіт, дорогі студенти, мене звати
Ольга Манма, і ласкаво просимо на наш сьогоднішній урок англійської мови,
ми проведемо дуже
цікаву роботу, оскільки ви знаєте, що для
вивчення будь-якої мови потрібно отримати
чотири навички, найпоширенішим є
вибір наступного  Далі йде читання, письмо,
а потім слухання. Я
викладаю англійську майже 20 років,
дуже часто мої студенти кажуть добре, я
знаю, як читати, я вмію писати, і як
дуже вогонь говорив, однак
слухати автентичну мову для носіїв
мови досить складно, тому  сьогодні
ми будемо багато
слухати, і це буде дуже
цікаво, повірте мені, давайте почнемо так, як ви
можете бачити з кімнати, і, як ви
пам’ятаєте, ймовірно, з нашого попереднього
уроку, технології – це те, що ми
відкриваємо зараз технології у світі  про
технології, коли я чую технології,
я думаю про науку, космічні чорні діри
з'являються пізніше, так, і, звісно,
рія Великого вибуху, тому ласкаво просимо на сьогоднішній урок.  по
на перший слайд, у нас є чорні діри
, на цій картинці красиво, я вважаю це
чудовим неймовірним неймовірним. Просто
уявіть, що ми живемо в цьому Всесвіті добре,
а як щодо теорії Великого вибуху так,
це не та серія, про яку ви,
напевно, чули  і всі ці кумедні
персонажі Теорія Великого вибуху була
відкрита, і дослідник,
вчений Стівен Хокінг,
він працює над нею деякий час, тож
давайте готуймося до нашого гарного прослуховування
на екрані, ви побачите деякий
словниковий запас, давайте зіставимо слова без
вас  далі тут, у розповіді
зі словами праворуч, перший
надзвичайний давайте шукатимемо синонім
так, що незвично страждати від о
так мати хворобу, щоб отримати ступінь так
, тобто мати освіту, насправді
мати доступну бакалаврську освіту
так  звичайно, це доступний
зовнішній вигляд чи вираз обличчя,
або ви можете сказати жест і виграти
стипендію зазвичай це коли ми говоримо
про educati  це вчитися
безкоштовно, коли всі ваші гонорари покриті, добре, добре,
добре, а як щодо цих чудових
виразів, хоча так, хоча я
подумаю про речення з,
хоча він був не дуже добре, він занадто
брав участь у заході або
наступному  замість замість того, щоб замість того, щоб не
працювати і залишився вдома, він все одно
не брав участі ні Руй, це
добре, коли у вас є два негативу в
одному реченні ні я, ні мій друг не
любимо моркву о це неправда я
люблю моркву так дуже добре давайте  рухайтеся
далі, подивіться на фотографію Стівена Гокінга,
ви, мабуть, бачили
інтерв’ю з цим джентльменом, ви могли
б прочитати його книгу, або сьогодні ви
дізнаєтеся про його біографію про його життя,
повне Сафа, повне задоволення
та пристрасті до науки, яку він  зробив
увесь світ відомим про добро, оскільки для мене
ці слова описують його найкращого
видатного вченого, дослідника і
мрійника, напевно ви бачили
фотографії людини в інвалідному візку
Так, мої діти вважають, що ці фотографії
шокують, але, як тільки ви пояснили
їм, що це найпотужніший
учений, ймовірно, 20-го століття,
той, хто познайомився з нами, він навчив нас,
що таке Великий вибух, що таке чорні
діри, я поважаю  цей чоловік, яким
він є,
британський учений, який слідував своїй
мрії та пристрасті та продовжував жити
щасливим життям, незалежно від того, скільки він
страждав фізично, як ви знаєте, коли
вам дають будь-яке завдання, і це слухати
сьогодні, перш ніж слухати, перш ніж
почути  інформація, яку ви надаєте
список запитань, я завжди раджу
вам уважно їх прочитати, щоб звернути
увагу на ключові слова, тому що
це інформація, яку ви будете
шукати, коли слухаєте нашого слухача
, триватиме близько чотирьох хвилин,
що досить
Вам потрібен довгий шматок інформації, це аркуш паперу та
олівець, щоб мати можливість робити нотатки, які
допоможуть вам, коли у вас виникнуть
запитання, коли ви повернетеся до них і
виконайте вправу  давайте подивимося на
запитання
давайте прочитаємо всі запитання та
подивимося, зверніть увагу, усі запитання в
цій діяльності є правдивими/неправдивими, тому
вам не потрібно зосереджуватись на тому, чи
було це дано чи не було дано, чи
шукати  для точної дати, тож це лише
питання про активність істина/неправда номер один, яке
вивчав Стівен Гокінг, і
лікарі з Оксфорду та Кембриджа очікували, що він
проживе ще два роки після того, як йому
поставили діагноз БАС. Питання третє
Стівен Гокінг сказав, що він не
живе життям  з хворобою БАС і до того, як його
метою було зрозуміти Всесвіт, багато
людей дізналися його краще, коли він
опублікував
книгу, продану тиражем у 10 мільйонів примірників, і вона
була перекладена на 14 різних
мов, коли є числа
, зверніть увагу на це, будь ласка,
номер 7  Стівен не міг говорити, тому
він мав комп’ютерну програму з британським
акцентом, щоб розмовляти за нього номер 8.
Стівен отримав вільний політ у
космос з Virgin Atlantic прямо у нас
подивіться на всі вісім запитань. Я
пропоную вам тримати ці запитання
перед собою, коли ви слухаєте
історію, чи готові ви, давайте почнемо, Стівен
Хокінг був дуже особливим у багатьох відношеннях
, тому для цього тижневого подкасту
англійською мовою comm дивилися на
надзвичайне життя так, Хокінг був
найвідомішим вченим у світі, але він
також був найвідомішим у світі
хворим на хворобу рухових нейронів. Він народився в
Оксфорді в 1942 році і виграв стипендію
для вивчення фізики в університетському коледжі
Оксфорда, отримав диплом першого класу
з  1962 року і поступив до Кембриджського
університету, щоб пройти аспірантуру
з фізики та космології, і саме
під час навчання в Кембриджі йому поставили
діагноз БАС,
а в 1963 році незабаром після його
21-го дня народження лікарі очікували, що він
проживе.  ще лише два роки, але і він,
і його дівчина Джейн не
боялися того факту, що у Стівена
щойно діагностували невиліковну
хворобу, вони одружилися на двох  років потому і
мав трьох дітей, як ми всі
знаємо, Хокінг прожив ще
55 років і помер у віці 76
років, як він сказав, хоча
над моїм майбутнім нависла хмара, я зі своїм здивуванням виявив,
що насолоджуюся життям  у
теперішньому часі більше, ніж до того, як я почав
просуватися у своїх дослідженнях, він також
заявив, що
моя мета проста, це повне
розуміння Всесвіту, чому він є
таким, яким він є, і чому він взагалі існує, настільки
очевидно, що надзвичайно розумна і
рішуча людина, але  чому він став настільки
відомим, по-перше, через
його дослідження чорних дір, Великого вибуху
та того, як почався Всесвіт, але Річард все
це було в академічному світі, поки
він проводив дослідження, так, він
насправді досяг слави аж до
громадськість була стурбована
публікацією його книги короткої
історії часу від Великого вибуху до чорних дір
так, Хокінг вирішив у 1982 році написати
популярну книгу про Всесвіт, яка
була б доступною для пологів
Замість того, щоб публікувати в
академічній пресі, він підписав контракт
із масовим видавцем, він був опублікований
вперше в 1988 році, і він
швидко піднявся до вершини списків бестселерів
як у США, так і у Великобританії, і
залишився там  протягом місяців його було розпродано 10
мільйонів примірників і було перекладено
40 різними мовами,
без сумніву, він навіть з'явився на обкладинці Newsweek,
хоча саме його зовнішній вигляд
тримав його в оці громадськості, той факт, що
він мав ці дивовижні ідеї, але не міг
ходити.  ні розмовляти
так, він користувався інвалідним візком
з кінця 60-х років і вже
втратив голос, він використовував комп'ютерну
програму, щоб говорити за нього, хоча чомусь
наприкінці свого життя з мобільністю йому надали американський акцент
для
перекладу його мозкових моделей або
виразів обличчя в слова використовувалися все менші й складніші технології, але, можливо, поряд
із зображенням Гокінга, який перехилений
у кріслі, є
Так, у 2006 році Хокінг розповів
в інтерв’ю BBC, що одним із його
найбільших нездійснених бажань було
подорожувати в космос, почувши, що Річард
Бренсон запропонував безкоштовний політ у космос
з Virgin Galactic, що, звісно,
інг негайно погодився, тепер Стівен Го
інг є одним із них.  те, що він
любив найбільше, зірки, молодці, я
сподіваюся, що вам сподобалося слухати
біографію Стівена Хокінга, хіба він не
неймовірний так, щоб мати можливість продовжувати
працювати, незважаючи на всі труднощі, через які
йому довелося пережити найстаршому стражденцю, і,
безперечно, з  підтримка його
люблячої сім'ї та друзів правильно, я сподіваюся, що
ви отримали всі відповіді,
однак активність прослуховування завжди виконується
двічі, тож тепер у вас є можливість
послухати її ще раз, сподіваюся, у вас є
список питань, список відповідей тепер
готовий  переконайтеся, що так, давайте послухаємо
його вдруге. Стівен Хокінг
був дуже особливим у багатьох відношеннях,
тому для цього тижня подкаст англійською мовою
comm дивилися на  надзвичайне
життя так, Хокінг був найвідомішим вченим у світі,
але він також був
найвідомішим у світі
хворим на хворобу рухових нейронів; він народився в Оксфорді в
1942 році і виграв стипендію для вивчення
фізики в університетському коледжі Оксфорда,
отримав диплом першого класу  у 1962 році
і поступив до Кембриджського університету, щоб
пройти аспірантуру з фізики та
космології, і саме під час навчання в
Кембриджі йому поставили діагноз «
захворювання рухових нейронів», а це
був 1963 рік, невдовзі після його 21-го дня народження
лікарі очікували, що він буде жити.  ще лише
два роки, але і він, і його
дівчина Джейн відмовилися боятися
того факту, що у Стівена щойно
діагностували невиліковну хворобу, вони
одружилися через два роки і мали трьох
дітей, оскільки ми всі знаємо, що Хокінг
продовжував жити для  ще 55 років і
помер у віці 76
років, як він сказав, хоча
над моїм майбутнім нависла хмара, я зі своїм здивуванням виявив,
що насолоджуюся життям у
пресі  Він також
заявив, що моя мета проста:
повне розуміння Всесвіту,
чому він є таким, яким він є, і чому він взагалі існує,
настільки очевидно, що надзвичайно
розумна і рішуча людина, але
чому  він став настільки відомим, по-перше
, завдяки його дослідженням чорних
дір, Великого вибуху та того, як почався Всесвіт,
але Річард все було в
академічному світі, поки він проводив свої
дослідження, так, він справді досяг слави
громадськості.
стурбований публікацією своєї книги коротка
історія часу від Великого вибуху до
чорних дір
так, Хокінг вирішив у 1982 році написати
популярну книгу про Всесвіт, яка
була б доступною для широкого
загалу, замість того, щоб публікувати в
академічній пресі, він підписав  контракт
з масовим видавцем, він був опублікований
вперше в 1988 році і швидко піднявся
до вершини списків бестселерів
як у США, так і у Великобританії, і
залишився там  протягом місяців його було розпродано 10
мільйонів примірників і було перекладено
40 різними мовами,
без сумніву, він навіть з'явився на обкладинці Newsweek,
хоча саме його зовнішній вигляд
тримав його в оці громадськості, той факт, що
він мав ці дивовижні ідеї, але не міг
ходити.  ні розмовляти так, він
користувався інвалідним візком з кінця 60-х років
і вже втратив
голос, він використовував комп'ютерну програму, щоб
говорити за нього, хоча чомусь
наприкінці свого життя з мобільністю йому надали американський акцент
Для перекладу його
мозкових моделей або виразів обличчя
в слова використовували дедалі менше, більш складну технологію, але, можливо, поряд із
зображенням Гокінга, який перехилився в кріслі
, є той, що він плаває, так, у
2006 році Хокінг показав в інтерв’ю BBC,
що один із його найбільших  нездійсненними
бажаннями було подорожувати в космос,
почувши це, що Річард Бренсон запропонував
безкоштовний політ у космос з Virgin
Galactic, що, звичайно,
Гокінг негайно  зараз добре прийнято Стівен Хокінг
є серед речей, які він любив
найбільше зірки молодці, молодці, давайте
разом розглянемо запитання й
подивимося, правий ти чи не правий,
однак я впевнений, що всі вісім відповідей
будуть правильними номер один Стівен
Хокінг  навчався майже в Оксфорді та
Кембриджі так, це правда, ми чули,
що чи не ми, лікарі очікували, що він
залишиться лише на два роки після того, як йому
поставили діагноз БАС, так, ми чули
, що він мав залишитися лише
на два роки
проте він дожив до
третього віку Стівен Хокінг сказав, що йому
сподобалося жити з БАС ні ні, це
неправда, він не турбувався про цю хворобу,
він продовжував працювати, громадське життя та
сімейне життя, хоча
зараз йому було погано.  Мета полягала в тому, щоб
зрозуміти Всесвіт, який є справжнім
Всесвітом, відкривши його, я був його
пристрастю номер п'ять, багато людей
дізналися його краще, коли він опублікував
правдиву книгу, і пам'ятати, що він вирішив
це зробити  він масовий видавець так, він
не хотів, щоб це було доступно
для наукового світу, він хотів, щоб
аудиторія всього світу була в
курсі всесвіту номер шість,
його книжка була продана десятьма мільйонами примірників і
була перекладена 14 різними
мовами  О, це складно, це
було не чотирнадцять, чи не так, це було правильно, номер
сім Стівен мав можливість говорити, тому він
мав комп’ютерну програму з британським
акцентом, щоб говорити за нього, о це дуже
весело,
що зробило всіх веселими, тому що
насправді  машина була створена з
американським акцентом, тому всі знали,
що Стівен Гокінг був британським
ученим, але мав американський акцент,
коли машина переклала його думки
та ідеї у словесний світ
Стівен отримав вільний політ у
космос з Virgin Atlantic так, це
правда, що  була його великою великою мрією, і вона
була доступна йому завдяки Річарду
Бренсону, який зробив її доступною, і це
було безкоштовно, тому його мрія побувати в
космосі здійснилася і з  на картинці
ви можете побачити, як він був щасливий, коли він
нарешті отримав це, а зараз О готуюсь
до уроку до сьогоднішнього уроку я
скажу правду, я не знав багато про
Стівена Гокінга раніше, але я познайомився з
ним, я дуже хотів  щоб потрапити в
біографію, я дійсно дізнався про
хворобу, яка є дуже рідкісною хворобою, і,
на жаль, у цього чоловіка вона була, але
тоді я подумав, що було так багато
красивих цитат про життя
про захоплення наукою і про мрії,
які Стівен Хокінг залишив для всіх
нас  Я ділюся з вами своїм улюбленим,
пам’ятайте, що дивіться на зірки, а не
вниз, до ваших ніг, намагайтеся зрозуміти
те, що ви бачите і хочете про те, що
створює Всесвіт, будьте цікавими, і яким
би важким життя не здавалося,
завжди можна щось зробити  роби і досягай успіху
, важливо, щоб ти не просто
здавався правильно, тому цей чоловік сказав всьому
всесвіту не здаватися, незалежно від того, в яких
умовах у вас є, у вас завжди є
вибір відповідати за те, що ви робите.
o слідуйте за своїми мріями, щоб слідувати своїм
пристрастям, дякую вам
[Музика].